society in general is having quite a
struggle with moving social interaction
online I mean let's let's leave it at
that very generic level social
interaction online let's talk about that
human social interaction has developed
over you know tens of thousands of years
and it's very complex and nuanced if I
share some information with you
you know basis of a lot of social Russia
sharing information sometimes you'll
choose to share with others and
sometimes you won't and those rules that
I've evolved over time are extremely
complex and subtle and if I tell you in
confidence when I'm upset about
something you know what happened and
what happened and you help me with that
I don't then expect for you to then to
pass it on to everyone else and those
sorts of when we get to real social
interaction those sorts of subtle ways
in which we share information is very
important to us as a society you know so
enter digitally enabled social
interaction and the key thing we have to
remember is that the computer in the
middle is not your best friend it
doesn't have the thinking part of your
friend
it'll pass on whatever information you
give and so today we are asked to go
through and set some access controls or
whatever mechanisms are in place to say
share this with this person but not this
person and of course as as individuals
we don't spend our lives writing these
rules down and showing them friends and
saying this is what I'm going to do we
expect that system to be actually you
know that our friends are much more
intelligent in the way that they would
pass some information and we
fundamentally have to face the fact that
computers are pretty stupid so you know
they don't do any of the filtering and
so people are often surprised if the
computer decides to share something it
will keep sharing that same information
over and over again and perhaps in the
future you know we could get to the
point where some learning capability is
programmed in such that if you get
annoyed with yet another candycrush
success from your friend you can go
please no more and it will actually
start filtering that content and it
might actually learn from
say maybe I won't tell them about any of
those stupid games and what's happening
because it's not really relevant I think
it's it's often very easy to get caught
out in this so we were just talking
earlier today about that a student is
working on a service that will represent
and you show you a map of what of where
you've tweeted from based on you know
the fact that you have location
information in your tweets now actually
a very small percentage of tweets of
location information in them and most
people don't use it however if you
occasionally do use it you might you
often find you forget to switch it off
and then you suddenly find out for the
last week it's been tweeting your
location and you didn't realize it so
that's another you know once the
computer starts doing something if
you've given it a rule that will
continue to execute that rule and that
can lead to you know unexpected
behaviors I think in general as well as
if there's a fundamental problem here
that privacy is a by itself it's for
many it's an abstract concept in the
sense of its daily what is privacy
people relate to real instant you know
incidents and it's usually unfortunately
when they or a friend has suffered as
our psychologist friends would call it a
harm they've suffered a harm and maybe a
minor thing like yeah a slightly rude
comment made about someone that
propagated where it shouldn't have done
you know kids getting upset about this
but you know can be much more much more
damaging than that and society in
general unfortunate and people in
general don't they don't abstract away
and think privacy they need to be
exposed to the harms before they'll say
well we should do something about this
and you know there's plenty of examples
of that of where you know a big you know
people have been talking about privacy
say philandering footballer
no one cares in general even though it's
still a privacy violation but when it
comes to you know a teenage girl then
suddenly it's outrageous and we have we
have reviews of you know the press and
everything so people have to be able to
associate themselves with a harm and
understand what it means and that that's
one of the challenges we have in this
area of is we don't want to have to
suffer
the harms before we build technologies
that are actually much more socially
acceptable and understanding I've become
quite unknown renown for jumping on
people
conferences when they say things like
people don't care about privacy anymore
and Luke what people are putting on
Facebook and I think it's actually very
interesting to Luke over the last few
years and really what's been happening
there and give something counter
examples this idea that everyone's just
given up on privacy and releasing
everything so for example there's been a
big migration away from you know posting
things on your wall on Facebook and
being opened by default and a whole
generation of teenagers have learned
that not to do that and in fact many of
them have adopted the instant messaging
function inside Facebook so that that
the messaging is now ephemeral it's it's
it's temporary and in fact if you're not
in the conversation you don't get to see
what was there and essentially what
you're seeing is the emergence of the
re-emergence of school ground rules
right
you're either standing in the
conversation and you were part of the
conversation or you weren't and joining
the conversation doesn't get you to see
what was said before and would you leave
you stop being part of the conversation
and in fact subtly that groups dynamics
change every time someone enters or
leaves the group and you take the
extreme example sitting around a dinner
you know dinner and party with your
friends having a conversation you know
and three-year-old child Potter's in
they've got out of bed the conversation
naturally changes tone to be overlooked
puts a three-year-old in the room we
don't and we don't write rules for this
we just do it so I think it's
interesting to look at hi for example
Facebook was then appropriated and used
in a way that in one sense wasn't
natural for Facebook
it basically is group instant messaging
and that's because people are trying to
re-establish the natural pattern of
social communication and impose it on
the media and in fact of the observation
of that behavior certainly has led some
kids to just say well why even using
Facebook then on
other things and in fact there was one
movement for a while towards going back
to Scottie play even going back and say
well just use that that's really good
for a group chat so why do I use
Facebook when you can do that and of
course the blossom you know of other
applications like whatsapp and snapchat
these are all people trying to impose
upon the technology or at least say
technology companies reacting to the
social interactions that people really
want to have rather than what is
actually a fairly unnatural social
interaction of sharing with everyone I
want to make one exception here for
Twitter and the reason I make an
exception for Twitter is that I would
say the vast majority of people using
Twitter in fact are using it to
represent their brand and I mean that
literally whether it's a company or
whether it's an individual who's a
celebrity or whether it's me when I'm on
Twitter I am living my brand I am an
academic researcher I'm very concerned
about certain topics and that's what I
tweet about and if you look at the vast
majority of Twitter it's actually people
right there are representatives there's
a there's an amount of it that's used by
people talking to their friends but in
many ways lots lots of people who cuz I
don't know why would you use Twitter for
this it's an inappropriate Channel I
have to say you know when I first heard
about snapchat I did have a discussion
with my kids and I looked at it and I
knew that one of the concerns would be
that especially on an iPhone you only
have to press two buttons quickly and
you've got a copy of the screen and very
happy to to let you know that my 14 year
old knew that already
and said yes people are fools if they're
posting on anything on there so it's a
step forward in the sense that it's
closer to school gun rules but it's
still not quite the same I mean if
someone got out a camera or a you know a
recording device and you're standing
around having a chat you were going what
are you doing of course we're about to
see that we're about to see someone
standing in a group with Google glasses
on and the question is who's going to
punch them in the nose first
therein lies one problem which is as we
get to very small numbers of atoms the
behavior we rely upon the quantum
mechanics behavior of the transistor
probability book images understand you
build things too high they fall over or
that what that doesn't work